[Music]
thank you so much thank you for sharing
your valuable time with us it means a
lot
my name is Ennis Amrit I'm a product
manager with Google cloud in networking
and I will be sharing the stage with URI
and with Bennett so we wanted to spend
some time in this next to share with you
what are the progress that we've made in
terms of network telemetry and security
telemetry and give you an overview on
how you can asset estimator as a partner
can utilize the visibility tools that we
are providing with with the cloud so as
you are moving or Center price or
customer are moving more of your
deployments and applications to the
cloud you are relying on us to as a
platform to provide with the
infrastructure that provides you with
the underline networking with the
underlying capabilities that comes with
obviously a lot of responsibilities we
need to provide you with the same
visibility as you're having for your
data center deployment so that you can
understand the signals that are
meaningful for your deployments and for
your applications and then you can take
actions based on based on that so in
order to provide the visibility it is
important that we are giving you with
information either to validate the
intent of your deployment so that you
know that the latency the throughput the
patterns of your network are matching
your intention all we need to give you
the signals to alert or notify of
potential deviation of that
of that intention and how are we doing
that we as a platform are able to
provide the networking signals and
visibility at the scale we are providing
the visibility without taking up
performance impact in your applications
and we'd also provide in near real-time
capability so that you can actually see
what's happening
in your network at almost at the same
time that is happening I'll go into more
details on how is that so for us as as a
platform we are treating really network
telemetry and security telemetry as
similarly as a big data problem we are
able to scale our infrastructure to
provide you that visibility without you
having to worry about what it means to
to your applications but also we are
ingesting and the data in our for
example bigquery for data for big data
processing and the volumes that we are
that we are generating we are in
real-time being able to export to either
your partner tools or bigquery or
pub/sub streaming so that you can
integrate with the best way for you to
extract the signals we are adding the
capabilities of the telemetry at every
pass I'll go in detail on what those
paths are and what exactly looks like
but you can see the signals for traffic
that is from your public facing
applications from the internet if
they're sitting behind a load balancer
you will get telemetry associated to
that you also can see the traffic that
is in and out every VM instance or DKIM
deployment and you can as well see the
traffic that it goes back and forth from
our BM instances to the Google managed
services for example storage
big data analytics like bigquery or
BigTable so basically everything that
it's in and out our infrastructure will
be able to visualize so let's go exactly
on what are the capabilities so as I
said we are uniquely positioned to
provide the scale and the near real-time
capabilities for your deployments and
this is something that we are very proud
of the fact that we are able to provide
you with aggregation of the flows that
are going on in in our network for your
deployments aggregated at five seconds
so you will see an aggregated set of
logs every five seconds which is again
almost near real-time we will do that at
the scale so you don't really need to
worry about what the throughput is your
application and how much data you are
generating we are able to perform the
telemetry of those without taking an
impact on your applications and on top
of that we are as well adding
annotations to those traffic flows where
it is meaningful like for example if
there is a flow from traffic from or to
the Internet then we are adding
annotations from the autonomous system
number or the new location of the public
IP so then when you are actually getting
the information you not only get you
know the five tuples and the what the
actual flow look like but you also see
annotations that we as a platform are
able to add in those logs so that you
can have more information that may be
meaningful for those specific traffic
paths alright so which are the user
journeys that we are targeting with our
products so Network Diagnostics so that
you can have an correlation of what is
your application performance and what
are the underlying what is the
underlying performance of of your
network so for example you might be
interested on what is their specific
latency RTT or the throughput generated
by a specific application or you may be
actually interested in diagnosing why
traffic might be succeeding or failing
from or 2bm instance so you're able to
go to the fine-grained granularity of a
specific endpoint filtering to a
specific IP and get the metrics latency
RTT throughput that are associated to
that we're also going to allow you to
see whether a specific connection was
allowed or denied by a firewall rule to
see you know if a specific connection
from an application succeed or or fail
and and why we as well target in network
usage and planning so that you can
actually validate that the patterns in
your network are according to what you
will expect so if you instead of
swimming swimming into a specific end
point you go to a more aggregated level
you can see whether for example you know
traffic from application a an
application B is going within the same
region it is not going out the internet
you will be able to see what are the
traffic that is for example exiting
Internet and what if they do locations
that the traffic is taking you will be
as well able to see what is the traffic
that is going through a VPN or through
inter connect to your data center so
that you can understand and as well you
can as well do filter through in your
applications so you can see for your
different development teams
what is the paths and the bandwidth that
they are taking and how the overall
distribution of the network looks for
your
for your deployments finally we have as
well more maybe Security's centric use
cases one of them it's the network
forensics and hold it so that you are
able to log in your deployments what is
the traffic or the connections that
where allow or deny by by your firewalls
and then you're able to store it for
future processing so you will be able
for example to ingest it into a storage
come back in the future and see at a
specific point in time what exactly was
happening in your network world worse
the connections that were going on if
you need to provide you know proof of a
specific traffic patterns a specific
point in time what where the connections
that were allowed or deny you can just
store it in storage in GCS in Google
Cloud storage and just come back for for
analysis and as well you are able
because we as well providing the
analysis in near real time you can see
security patterns some layers that you
will be able to visualize if you are
concerned about the specific flows
exiting for example to the internet
you're able to see those signals in in
real time let's talk specifically so
that's all very good you know we have a
bunch of use cases that we need to solve
for but really what does it mean like
how do I actually what are the set of
tools that I am going to be using forum
for those so to start with and I'm going
to start you know from maybe a
public-facing
to endpoints that are sitting in in your
be pieces we are going to provide with
internet-facing
apps load balancer telemetry and then
you can see the utilization the usage
you can see the request responses which
codes are certain requests
actually you can see latency associated
to your load balancers front-end
back-end you can as well then go to your
endpoints in your VP CBM instances your
google kubernetes engine nodes and you
can see with PPC flow logs what are the
network flows that we're coming in and
out from a specific BN instances in
points and again it really you're able
to get those signals for every for every
path federal logs will allow you to
obtain based on your configuration of
login specific firewall rules will allow
you to get all the attempts Fargo locks
is not a sample functionality we'll go
more into the detail but it will give
you every connection that it was
attempted either allow or deny by a
specific firewall rule in which you have
chosen to configure login and finally
I'll give you a little bit of a teaser
of something that we are opening to
trusted testers which is network
topology visualization tool which it
will give you a topology relationship of
your applications and deployments and
then metrics and that are associated to
specific path so it is really getting
the data and give it you a little more
of a visual view of it let's start with
the load balancer telemetry so as I said
it works for your HTTP HTTPS load
balancers TCP is a self proxy and it is
very rich set of metrics it will give
you signals as well at the front end at
the at the back end I'll do a little bit
of a demo so that you can get a sense of
where is the information on how you can
actually visualize it and it gives you
latency metrics throughput metrics for
anything that it's really sitting behind
a load balancer public facing PPC flow
logs is something that we've been
working very intense in the last year we
went in ur availability about I think
maybe a few weeks ago we are able to
provide the throughput and latency in in
every path we're doing again near
real-time which is pretty pretty unique
we provide a lot of information that you
can ingest through a stack driver export
you don't really need to use a stack
driver as a login mechanism they export
it could allow you to go to pops up or
integrate with your sim or any partner
of your choice and we really work with
unintegrated with a lot of partners so
to provide you a variety of different
ways of visualize and get your signals
finally as I said we're providing the
the annotations one of our customers
that have been using
bpc flow logs I was actually just
telling me last week that they were able
to log in 120 billion of flows our
records and then that they got a speed
of processing of their of their signals
in the network over a hundred times of
what they were able to do before so
we're very excited to provide this the
level of skill and
and speed with BBC flow looks firmer
looks it's currently in alpha and maybe
some of you have been already using it
there is a very specific difference
between Fargo locks and AM BBC flow logs
farewell locks is really more sexy
centric features so we are not some
plane we are logging in every attempted
connection whether it is deny or or
allow and they look and feel and the way
you are exporting to your tools are
really very similar as the V PC flow
looks on I'll show you a little bit but
you can actually export through stock
driver again through the export
capabilities you don't really need to
use a stock driver that's a login but
you can you will choose to do that as
well but you can export to directly to
the through pub/sub for example to the
partner of your of your choice and we
others will annotations so specifically
we add the specific configuration of the
firewall rule at the point in which the
traffic was either allow or deny so you
can actually match it up the action that
was taken for the five toppled against
what that specific firewall rule was
looking at the time that action was
taken and as well we aggregate every
every five seconds we do that as well
for ingress and egress firewall rules in
terms of exporting I'll I already
mention a little bit but we're just
using the same mechanism so that you can
actually use the same export in
mechanisms for your BBC flow logs for
your Fargo logs and then you configure
your able to set up filters of what you
want to send to the restart driver or
what you actually want to send to a
storage maybe for long term analysis if
you want to keep the data for coming
back later or you can send it to pops up
or to bigquery if you want to have your
own
data processing analysis based on their
on the flow logs so a lot of choices and
we do not really have any it is not
really mandatory that you ingest into a
star driver itself you can just directly
export to to where you do your choices
and finally I'll assign as I mentioned I
want to encourage you to go to deaf to
1/3 a session we're going to be showing
there a little bit more of what we're
doing in terms of network topology
visualization and again we're opening
two trusted testers for getting your
data into into the tool you will it's it
looks very similar than the if you've
seen in the keynote a stock driver is
still visualization it's really the same
look and feel but more from a network
perspective so that you can see
aggregated data more at the
infrastructure rather than extracting
the service visualization
now you can as well filter in and out in
terms of swimming in specific
applications but for example you see
traffic from on to your data center
froma to internet etc alright so we
thought that i'm going to do a quick
walk through let's see can we switch to
demo please
No
the connection is not
yes
no oh cool all right
yay are you working
yeah kind of walk out without showing
you guys so cool all right so I'm I have
configured some load balancers so you
see my shop inside load balancer you
know it has a global way please ceptin
HTTP traffic now I do have certain
patrols for my load balancer and those
are those URLs have been served by
different backends so for example I have
my bras which is serve eyebrows back and
scar to survive car backends and each of
those as well
like for example if I go down browse
backends they have backends points in
Asia Europe us so I'm able to see
certain information here what is the
usage and capacity but if I go to
monitoring then I'm going to be able to
see what is the RPS per button and
something really cool Isis what is the
distribution of my traffic been served
for specific the connections from Asia
are being served by balance in Asia
connections in North America by my
condition North American I can see how
many requests per second additionally I
can go to stack driver and then I see I
have here for example my car backends I
can see a breakdown for example by
backing song I can see what the
latencies I can see
I can latency I can send the front end
round-trip time I can see my requests
per second for each of the zones so
again I've done a breakdown persona I
can for example choose match URL and
then I'm going to see my matrix now
filtered by the specific URL so each of
them is going to be one URL that is
served by a a set of back ends so this
gives you a little bit of sense of what
we have for load balancer is pretty rich
set of of metrics for BBC BBC flow looks
for example I have I guess I had it
already on the screen so I don't need to
walk through that but I have in a
network a BBC network I have specific
subnets
in different regions and I have own for
us central subnet BBC flow locks on for
during central subnet and Europe West
if I click I'm able to actually edit say
I want to have it on or I want to have
it off it actually also tells me how
much of the locks I will be generated so
you can estimate what's going to be the
volume associated to the traffic so now
if I look into what the flow locks are
actually looking like you can see maybe
zoom in a little bit so sorry maybe zoom
out so you can see more in the screen
you can see that we are generating
records the connection 5 topple in this
case the destination IP is a public IP
the source IP is a private IP I can see
the source port and the protocols and
then I can see the destination it was
public IP so then I can see the ASN
the continent and the country that it
was generated I can see my matrix so I
can see the run through time I can see
the number of packets and then a bunch
of annotations related to the instance
they'd be pieces so and actually it is
real time as you see line is generating
a lot of streaming data so you can see
it is really loading all day all the
records for Federal Rules I have it
configured for one firewall yes as an
example allow DC LV I am accepting
traffic from the source ranges and from
a protocol eighty so now if I actually
go to my view instead of actually
checking the BBC flow logs I check
firewall and then I'm going to say for
example if I click this one I'm going to
see the connection that I was allowed by
which firewall and actually get the
details of what that specific firewall
was again at the point in time in which
this was configured the source ranges
what you saw it was configured and it
applies to a set of instances um and
again you know real-time and it gets
updated as the traffic is hitting those
firewall rules finally again I'm just
going to show you a little bit of what
this is going to look like we are
providing a visualization tool which is
this is open to trusted servers and then
what you're gonna say is in the stunt
driver topology you will be able to load
the topology of your applications in
this case I have a load balancer I do
have traffic from a specific
like for example if I click here I'm
going to be able to see the matrix so
for example so you can see you cannot
see very well but you can see the
traffic that is generating for a
specific path in this case from Asia to
u.s. central back ends in that load
balancer and with that I'm going to
welcome to state jury who's they take
lead that's behind a lot of the
technology that is powering our network
telemetry please switch back to a
presentation mode thank you
hi so before I begin I just wanted to
mention that there's gonna be a Q&A
session after this meeting and if you'll
go to the application of GCP next from
this session you should probably see
their link toward dory where you can
submit and vote on questions so my name
is Yuri
I'm the tech lead for VPC vlogs and I
kind of wanted to give you some
engineering background as to how we
generate VPC vlogs and what are the
methods that we are using and that's
kind of to give you a general feeling as
to the capabilities of this tool so to
generate the PCF logs we start by
sampling connections we sample packet
packet headers on all connections coming
through and from a VM and by sampling
packet headers we are able to monitor
connection behavior over time if you
have one Prem set ups you're probably
familiar with tools such as natural and
s flow which have a very similar
approach so from every packet that we
sample we extract a piece ports and
protocol in order to uniquely identify a
connection we sample as close to the VM
as possible in order to ensure that we
are seeing the same IP addresses as
specified by the VM and this ensures us
that you will be able to correlate with
receive flow Logs with other data
sources that you might have for example
if you're running agents on your VM to
collect the same type of data every five
seconds we combine all of the headers
that we've seen for each connection and
by keeping track of sequence numbers we
are able to estimate packet count on the
connection by looking at the payload
size we are calculating throughput and
for TCP connections very enough packets
were captured we are able to correlate
seek and knock timestamps to estimate
our TT as experienced by the connection
so get gathering the information is one
thing but making sure that it's accurate
is is kind of difficult so for network
monitoring tools accuracies of the
highest importance to make sure that we
have high accuracy we try to sets our
sampling rate to the highest value
possible to do that we do not just set a
constant sampling rate but we adjust our
sampling rate in real time to the
highest value possible without exceeding
set resources this sampling rate is
being captured per packet to make sure
that we are compensating correctly for
the packets that we do not see
furthermore we then we then measure the
accuracy of our system against a
separate disjoint system just to make
sure that our pipeline is not only
available but that its accuracy is
intact although IPS and ports are in the
backbone of our reports it's not
necessarily the most useful identifiers
for VPC flow logs sometimes when you
look at connections of VMs for example
that no longer exists or you look at a
Pierre dresses they do not belong to
your network those are hard to make
sense of in order to tackle that problem
in while we process the data in real
time we combine the data with metadata
from your project and we are able to
annotate GCP endpoints with VM
identifiers VPC identifiers and for
external endpoints we are able to
annotate geolocation such as country
city and region which enables you to
search and filter VPC flow logs by those
fields so for example if you're
interested in seeing traffic between two
VMs you can do that or if you are
interested in seeing traffic from
certain region to a certain country you
can do that as well so there are a lot
of use cases for network monitoring
tools many of which require data that is
fresh one of those use cases one that is
close to my heart is debugging
large-scale systems and our collection
system was built with that in mind
so after collecting data for five
seconds we spend additional four second
processing this data and we are sure
those good times by making sure that our
pipeline is distributed in all clouds
owns so that the data is being processed
near where it was sampled then after
additional ten seconds this data is
available for your use so if you're
running a scenario on your network
you're able to see relevant VPC flow
logs for this scenario with in under 20
seconds from what when that happened now
every DCP project is unique some
projects are small and have very few VMs
but some projects are large and have
very complicated networks our pipeline
currently is already handling a very
large portion of GCP traffic those
belonging to early adopters of abusive
logs and to end beta users so those the
amount of EPC flows currently amounts to
millions of records per second and we
experienced no performance impact on
user compute or network resources so you
should not hesitate enabling VPC flow
logs for your network keep in mind that
enabling those those logs may result in
substantial amount of traffic but
bigquery cloud logging and pub/sub are
provision to handle them if you choose
to use them so as long as you can ingest
this data we are able to provide
the other project our team is working on
is firewall logging so firo logging is
collected differently than VPC flow logs
because the use cases for fire were
logging are a bit different than those
from seafloor logs for VPC flow logs we
wanted to ensure that our users are able
to monitor connection behavior over time
for fire logging the existence of the
connection is more important than its
behavior so feral logs are generated per
firewall event so every time the
connection is created or a connection is
denied irrelevant log will be created to
do so we keep a connection table for
every VM and every time we add a new
connection to the table table we will
generate a firewall rule forever log for
connections that were denied we will
report each time that a connection was
attempted in order to enable security
use cases by taking this approach we are
able to guarantee higher with higher
confidence that we will report on every
relevant connection so firewall looks
very similar to VPS if the logs are
reported in near-real-time which means
that a after a connection is created you
are able to see relevant log in just few
seconds we guarantee that we can capture
up to a hundred connections per second
for every cord that is provisioned for
your VM and we do that without any
performance impact on your computer
resources firewall logs just as VPC flow
logs are annotated in real-time with
metadata from your project and in
addition to annotating VM instances and
geo locations we also
buying those logs with relevant firewall
rules so that your you can easily use
them thank you is that I'm gonna
introduce Annette who's gonna talk about
our partner ecosystem Thank You Yuri my
name is vini bond
I lead security partnerships for Google
cloud so I work with third-party
security companies so in addition to
what Innes and Yuri explained in terms
of technology that Google has built we
also work very closely with the leading
security companies in logging and
monitoring companies to bring solutions
to you that are innovative as well as
for solutions that are you currently
using on prem or in your private cloud
deployments you can use the same
solutions in google cloud as well so
I'll explain the different aspects that
will be relevant as you're thinking
about logging and monitoring so in terms
of partner solutions I would not cover
all of them today I will just cover some
of the categories and mention only some
of the partner names there is a lot
going on with many partners you know we
don't have enough to cover everybody so
generally speaking if you think about
which categories of partners would be
relevant you know the first and foremost
would be the same vendors so we have the
companies like sumo logic and Splunk who
have pre-built GCP apps so it'll be very
easy for you to ingest use those apps
ingest the data and you know use the
visualization tools that you're very
comfortable with so the same vendors
would be obviously as something you
should be looking at the next generation
firewall partners that we have obviously
when the traffic is flowing through the
next-gen fire was they have lot of
visibility into the traffic so their
visualization tools are very relevant as
well
I'll explain a couple of examples there
as well the third category is the
compliance vendors which are more new
born in the cloud kind of companies like
red lock dome 9 and how they are
integrating it with vbc flow logs to
give you very good visualization
solutions and security on top of that so
I'll explain a couple of examples there
as well so there are broad category of
partners that you can look at to you
know give you the visibility as well as
more security analytics on top of that
so if you just double-click on the first
category within same partners you know
strong consumer logic are the ones that
I mentioned this is a picture of a sumo
logic avi PC app that was released very
recently and it gives you great
visibility in on the traffic profile as
well as their kind of integrations they
have done with stag driver and other
pieces of Google services they all get
near real-time dashboards that you can
use so these are pre-built dashboards
you know just you can go to sumo logic
download them ingest the data and the
visualizations already exist so very
easy to leverage them similarly this is
an example of a sumo logic app they have
built for firewall logging so the great
innovation that in this and you reciate
about all the data that we are
collecting a pre build app from sumo
logic as an example could be a great
place to ingest that data and visualize
it in a very easy manner the next
category of partners are the next-gen
firewall partners that we mentioned so
this is Palo Alto Networks you have been
working with Palo Alto team for a long
time so this is kind of the integration
work we have been doing with them so all
the traffic is flowing through Palo Alto
Networks in this case customer wants to
use their firewall so all the rich data
that they are collecting and adding to
the data that they see would be visible
through their dashboard so panorama for
example can also correlate the different
things that you are seeing the path the
Palo Alto firewall is saying so if
you're using a Palo Alto firewall you
know in addition to the same you could
obviously use the pool all two
interfaces as well another example is
checkpoint another firewall partner that
we have you know in addition to the
logging data you can also look at you
know how they detect threads and how
they're doing an anomaly detection on
top of just looking at flow so this is
another example of existing tools that
you may be comfortable leveraging on
Prem same tools available in GCP as well
so the third category of partners I
wanted to mention was the compliance
partners you guys may have you know
worked with some of them in this case
this is the red lock we've been working
closely with them as well they have been
done a integration into VPC flow logs so
the graph
that you see on the chart is the VPC
flow log implementation and the
visualizations they have built on top of
it so in addition to the visualization
they also you know do things like
detecting crypto mining and other
security on top of the data they're
collecting so these are very good tools
as well to take a look at as you're
thinking about you know how do I
visualize and and monitor the network
that I'm building so another example in
that category is dome 9 you know partner
for more than a year for us you know
have done similar flow log integrations
so in their example for example you can
see the traffic that you're receiving
from malicious IPS so they have an IP
reputation list so bad IP sending
traffic to your V PC you can usually
visualize what's going on so that's just
kind of phew partner examples I wanted
to give in addition to that there are
some products that Google has built that
some of you may have heard about the
cloud security command center so this
was announced in the March timeframe
it's a visualization framework that
gives you visibility into the services
that you're running on GCP provides
interesting security insights and it's a
flexible platform where you can change
the visualization based on your needs so
this is a great platform to leverage
that Google has built to see the
visualization of all the and get all the
telemetry and metering and bit logging
in one place so a very interesting
aspect of the command center is it
ingest data from Google services so you
can have all the data that Google can
see in addition you also have partner
integrations there so you could have the
partners that I mentioned Palo Alto
Network dome 9 red log you can have all
the data the security signalling they
are seeing also push to the command
center so command center becomes your
one dashboard to look at you know the
third-party products as well as Google
products and get one place of getting
all the data and we will continue to
work with these partners invest more and
move towards you know automating once
the data is is visualized how do we help
you kind of solve those problems react
to certain threats so we will continue
to work with these partners to make you
know security monitoring easier and
easier so towards the end you know we
have done all these you know
integrations
I wanted to share some of the things
that we are hearing from partners very
similar to what what NSA and Yuri
mentioned what people are really liking
about what you should think about is the
near real-time capability so seeing it
at Google interfaces or partner
interfaces that we believe it's kind of
very important and differentiated for us
and not having to worry about you know
how much logging resources or how much
resources what login consume is is also
very helpful as well as you know the ASN
and other things that we are appending
so I think customers have received it
very well we're getting very positive
feedback looking forward to hearing more
from you guys as well yeah and continue
to build build more and more products
[Music]